okay hi everyone welcome to a design
review looking at calculus and algebra
for the upcoming version of language
all right let's just take a rough look
at what we've got here
so
okay
lots of special functions
what on earth is this
okay so fox h
continues it's it's
right into
uh fox h reduce
uh will take other special functions and
produce whenever possible
one or several fox you know what
we could have a coulomb h1 reduce as
well
no
no those are too special it only makes
sense for these very general functions
okay absolutely not let's talk about
this we've already got function reduced
right
no we don't
no we don't we function expand
oh function expand right totally
different okay okay okay okay maybe we
need a function reduced
um no you really want the target
no no i i understand we need a target
right but what i'm saying is i don't
think we should have i mean we've
already got trig expand trigger reduce
all those kinds of things
those functions are very hard to use for
me at least
because i can't really remember which
thing what the target really is and
what's going on and so on well maybe we
should have a sort of a general reduce
but we can't this one
this one is is more sophisticated than a
general purpose one would be
you know in the sense that
uh you can actually use the output the
other one is sort of general purpose
output maybe you can use it maybe
look the fact is this is producing as as
my understanding is it's producing some
fox h clump
right and that's a fine thing to do it
sounds useful
okay but what i'm suggesting is that we
basically you know this is the thing
that has been coming upon us for decades
right the need to have some kind of
you know uh function transformation
by
described output type thing
sure yes and i think you know look why
don't we
tag this as experimental for 13 this fox
h reduce
and expect that
because you've got inactive forms being
produced and so on here right this is a
complicated mess
of of ideas
which i think we need to think about but
we can i mean i don't mind tagging into
experimental um but there would be
another function that is a general
purpose of course
exactly right and yeah but what happens
to this one depends on what the design
of that general function ends up being
and you know whether this function is in
the end needed or not you know that can
be decided later
making sense that's fine
but i think you know so we should be
starting to think about you know because
there are a couple of issues here for
function reduce one is
how do we describe the targets
sure and two is
what you know what is the is the target
going to be inactivated all those kinds
of things and it would be good to have a
central way to decide that
making sense i mean and similarly
there's a question of is the source
inactivated and how much does it pay
attention to an activated source and how
much does it not
mess with the inactivated functions
there
sure
so what what's the right meeting to talk
about a function reducer is it best to
just leave it to you guys to think about
that in the first instance i think in
the first instance yes okay because this
is massive this is a massive undertaking
with a lot of um
uh and i wouldn't call them simplifiers
but they're simplifier-like
transformations but we have a bunch and
we have all kinds of gamma simplify
we've had we've had these for years we
just haven't had quite enough that it
makes sense to put a big super function
together to do them
but we i think we're starting to have
enough and my feeling is that the you
know
gosh i mean i had these things
in smp i had the idea that you would
just have collections of rules that did
this that was too naive right but but i
think what you know the question is
there are many potential things you know
like for instance you can you can draw a
big graph of the possible
transformations you can use the
structure of that graph to figure out
whether there is a path
things like that sure um that's a really
nice thing to think about but but i i
don't i can't give time i mean no no no
i know i know i'm i'm just this is the
point of these reviews is to understand
you know the bigger picture and i mean i
think to me the function reduce idea
there are two things one could describe
one can basically describe the edges on
that graph and one can describe nodes
one can say what you're going to do and
one can describe what form you want it
to end up in
seems to me and both are valid kinds of
descriptions and my guess is that that
the right way to do this is essentially
with
um you know with a string name for
destinations so the ones
yeah i mean the ones that we have now
that you see here they're there for a
very good reason like differential
reproduce difference root reduce mayor g
reduce fox h reduce those four
because they actually trigger reduce too
but from that's from a previous era but
those end forms that you get
are value canonical in some sense yes
yeah i understand that makes perfect
sense i mean but there's also a gamma
simplify
at some point which is essentially
reducing i don't remember what that does
exactly but it's it's probably
i don't remember what that does it's
well we're gonna have to sort of where
we have to to
do archaeology basically right but i
mean i think my point about this is code
archaeology i mean i suspect that
there's an oleg a giant oleg collection
that exists somewhere for these but i
mean my point is i think we've reached
the point where we have enough of these
transformations that it's worthwhile to
have a general framework for them well
i mean
uh
yeah let's leave it at that many more to
say but it's we need we have a lot of
things to cover okay fine
um oh great did we finish obama since
stegen yes we did
is this it is this the end this is the
end
cool
including all that weird stuff at the
back of the book no
so that weird stuff the tests about sort
of a quarter of a page but they're not
really i mean okay they're odd you know
there's like i think that someone's
scratch notes or something
i mean all right okay they're not
seriously covered oh yeah okay
but there is a next generation which is
dlmf which is a digital library of
mathematical functions yeah which is the
sub uh successor to
abraham which is taken
yeah and we've known those guys since
before they existed so of course yes yes
the
all right well
okay
let's keep going
okay function poles
so we had that before didn't we or is
that completely new it's new
cool
what does it do with an essential
singularity
well that's not a poll
so it just says not a poll
no it's it's can't return it because
it's not a poll no i understand that but
i'm just trying to understand with a
branch cut for example
okay
and there's no ambiguity in branch cut
poles are poles
and you can't end up with a pole on one
riemann sheet and not on another ring
sheet is that true
might no
um
so what we introduced in 12 2 was
function singularities and function
discontinuities
they give you a complete description
even when they're infinitely many
so function poles can typically only
return finitely many poles
what does it do for the gamma function
uh if you restrict it to a finite region
it can return a finite collection of
poles what does it do when you haven't
restricted it i don't know you have to
try it yeah it should give you all them
maybe in this case it's regular enough
that it can get
but often it's not necessarily well
actually
you know i take that back
yes okay does give all of them
oh wait a minute
if i just have a random function here i
am not sure i like this very much at all
i mean if i if i'm just trying to do
the multiplicity
second argument is the multiplicity
well that's fine and dandy but what is
that object there that's a conditional
expression
but so if i'm going to consume this
let's say i want to sum over poles
yeah
how do i do that
there's an example as well but we can
yes we i mean there'll be different
functions strictly but there's an
application example that does just that
i i can believe you but i'm asking the
question but then there's going to be
another function we're going to for the
next version we're going to extend
residue to be able to give a condition
just as you give for this um
so you could that residue would
automatically sum over the poles
but what about saying i mean just like
we have root sum why don't we have pole
sum
no
i mean
that's that's what residue will do
basically but i don't understand residue
is at a point isn't it
yeah but you can sum over them
so what
i mean residue is just giving you
the the residue of the function at that
point right right but if you if if
z belongs to you know comma expression
there just is the same condition that
you can use for function poles
i'm saying like if you look at the
description of function polls if you go
back to call box
you can restrict it
see that cons i see that okay
if you do that same with residue you can
you can automatically sum over all the
poles in that
constraint set is that a usual thing to
think about as a residue of a region i
never heard of that before i only heard
about residues of poles
but that's usually what you do when you
see people write that sum out they say
that sums over poles i i know that but
i think it'd be better if we had a
function called pole sum because people
expect to be summing over poles and they
would expect if they see pole sum in a
piece of code they know oh it's the sum
of a poles whereas if they just see
residue they think that's just the
residue at a point
no that's that's what we've just done
for 30 years but there was no good
reason
i'm asking in standard mathematical
notation
[Music]
i understand but when people write out
res or something
in a math textbook right they mean the
residue at a pole they do not mean the
thing that you are describing which is a
sum over polls why not well they don't
do they well they usually i mean they
don't they're so textbooks just say fine
we can create a new function that does
did what they meant
to do
then then we just give it a new name for
that use case that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm fine
right i mean i'm just but but you could
you know if i'm wrong
make sure you tell me i'm wrong i mean
but my understanding is that when people
say residue in a textbook they mean
residue at a point is is adam here can
he speak to this please yeah i mean uh
adam is not here we can call him but but
i know that i've used this a lot and you
could either call it residues which
would be all recipes in the region or
called wholesome which i think makes
sense over here
so is it a pole somewhere is it residues
residues i would expect to be a list of
resin i mean i don't know what pole sum
is do you want to some poles i mean you
want to do a residue sound interfere
okay
okay that's a different issue but i
think the concept that it is a sum over
a region you know a sum over i mean
i don't know i would i would have
thought you say sum over poles but i
don't know we good to get adam here
because i think he would be a person who
would have something to say about this
could we maybe do that please
i'll try to get him
thanks
okay
so let's keep going here
uh i mean i'm i'm not totally thrilled
about this idea that of of either it is
a number
or it's this conditional expression
where are we using that and what
consumes that i mean if i do that
okay reduce consumes that but what about
generates that okay but what i'm asking
is
if i feed that into
i don't know how do i really use that
well i wanted to make residue be able to
consume it that's why i'm saying and
then if you're gonna make it consume it
why the hell call this function in the
first place
no i understand that but what i'm asking
is this
i've got a bunch of poles for example i
want to know how many poles are there
total in this function
right i say
i say length of that list obviously i'm
i'm toast if i do that similarly if i
look at the multiplicity here and i say
you know i just sum multiplicities i'm
toast because this is going to give me
the wrong answer
right so my question is
these operations that we do on this
output
i understand reduce
i mean what have we done for if if i say
function singularities here who's whose
function is that is that adam's function
function singularities yes okay so we
need i mean i am the one that has
actually sort of
okay
made it possible yeah okay
so now
there's no way that you can describe
singularities in in in a practical way
without using the implicit form i agree
okay so my question is this
you know we have plenty of things like
regions where we have an implicit form
of the region
but where the consumers of regions know
oh i can have an explicit region i can
have an implicit region
okay
the thing the problem with algebraic
expressions is
there is no wrapper
that says this is an implicit
representation we're just using boolean
expressions for example here
see what i'm saying
yeah
so i mean to me
no so the things that can consume this
let's say that you wanted
what it is you want to do with it
depends on okay
so for instance let's say you wanted
explicitly solving finding it find an
instance solve it reduce it will convert
can convert it into explicit forms
particularly if you constrain it to a
finite region you will get finite number
of things
so
[Music]
you know in a sense
what this is doing what function
singularities is doing
is it's giving you relations about the
functional singularities
yeah giving you it's giving you a finite
description of something that's
potentially infinite right
but
you know one other approach to this
might be
to have something where we basically say
you know
let's say we had a thing called implicit
expression
i don't know quite what that where where
basically what that does is
it is a rapper that says and this may
not be a good idea but i'm just trying
to work through what this means the
different the difficulty that i'm having
is
okay in this case i really really don't
like the fact that you can get something
which is
an implicit conditional expression here
or you can just get the number one i
mean in this case what you're getting is
always a relation that describes the
singularities yes
right
but in this case you're either getting
you know like if i if i gave a you know
if i if i did something like this
you know um
[Music]
you know great i'm going to get a bunch
of a bunch of poles
right yeah but if now what i do is i say
you know let's say i say
you know gamma of z
over that
it's like what the heck am i doing with
this
how do i deal with that
what consumes that
well the implicit form
you pretty much have to use one of the
solvers to convert i understand but but
so what i'm saying is
maybe what we need to do
i'm confused by what this is producing
okay
i mean in a sense
what we've got here is an implicitly
specified list i mean in a sense both of
these things at the end it's like we
have a list there are some explicit
elements and then there are some lazy
elements that aren't explicitly
specified
yes right and so the question is is
there some general way of thinking about
lazy elements in a list
which i think might be important for
other purposes too and this could use
such a mechanism
yeah i
okay so in this case one could clearly
you know have a set constructor or list
constructor that is a lazy
um thing
uh in general
i don't think so
well i suspect you're right expect it's
undecidable in general and things like
right right right so i mean we can't
give people the expectation it's going
to resolve but my problem is and let's
not take too long on this let's pin this
as an issue we need to talk about okay i
mean the the
okay i mean i don't this isn't quite
right i think
but let's you know we've got much more
in this agenda so let's go on to the
agenda and let's come back to this sure
okay
okay the next one i'm seeing is center
radius interval
yes
what is that
so that is a an interval specified by a
center and a radius either a really a
polar coordinate interval basically in
the column sort of except but this
cartesian product of them in the complex
case
it's not po i mean it's not circular in
the complex
but confusingly it's called ball
arithmetic
which is wait
wait wait wait
what do you mean it isn't circular in
the complex plane
look at the illustration
go back up
a bounding box it's no that's the actual
interval
how can it be called center radius and
not be a circle
because it that's
a that's a cartesian product that's what
it's called
it's crazy
why is it crazy because think about the
unit disc or something is the unit disc
described as a center radius interval no
it's not apparently okay do you have a
different name for it then well that's
what i'm thinking about yeah okay but
confusingly this whole thing is called
ball arithmetic too because this is a
perfectly good ball it's just a square
ball it means it's about a simple
that's the circle
why don't we call it complex interval
because it's real interval too
and in the other case when you give the
bounds the outer you know the the corner
bounds
numbers okay so you're saying it is
around a point
yes
just as a round gives a center and a
radius
but that's a stochastic that's a
stochastic type interval okay i get it
this is a deterministic type interval
okay i mean in the
what about in two dimensions is there is
there a version of this in two
dimensions not in complex plane no
wouldn't that also be useful i mean
doesn't doesn't does a round what does a
round do with with two-dimensional data
it has a vector version
where you can give um basically an
ellipse an ellipsoid so why doesn't this
support the same kind of thing
because it doesn't
why not
because it's not done okay but fine but
that's different question from what the
design should be
well this relies on the fact that
there's been a lot of work done on this
for special functions there's been
nothing done on vector variables i
understand but the design that we want
to make as a design a permanent design
hey but then i can bring up then i
should bring up my my all my vector
infinities you know i have a whole
[ __ ] model for that
why do people want that
you mean you mean as opposed to infinity
in a complex infinity of infinity in a
different direction
right
vector yeah i understand so those are n
infinities yeah right there are vectors
there are there are there's things where
there's a vector where both components
you know two two dimensional vector
where both components go to infinity at
different rates right
yes those are that's an interesting
object yeah but you can have the analog
of a complex infinity for rn or cn as
well
i get it
okay but let's come back to this okay
so what you're saying is
i mean i really really really don't like
that name if it's not going to be i mean
okay in the real case right
okay
let me understand
um
the things that we have about bounding
boxes and so on
we have this um
coordinate bounds coordinate bounding
box those kinds of things right
uh yeah
and we have we have bounding regions
that are much more sophisticated
i mean i understand i'm trying to come
up with a name here because we have this
notion of coordinate bounds which is in
the coordinate directions as this
creature is
right
right
and
i mean the fact that this is a box
is
i understand that the main thing you're
doing is you're specifying an interval
by its center which is a different thing
than we normally do with intervals
right
what about just center interval
sure get the radius yes we thought about
that actually centimeters looks good
shorter as well centered about centered
you're centered center right what do you
think i i don't know i mean so so let's
see the centered
interval
that seems pretty decent i think so we
thought that's a pretty good name
actually sure i think so okay all right
i mean that's that
that's also what's not there yet is the
the final sort of type setting right now
it's a summary box but you really don't
want that in big formulas full of them
for sure
what are you going to do with that uh
we don't have a prototype to look at yet
but we want something that's smaller
okay
um
all right it's a pretty good name
actually okay fine all right
um
there's a question here so sander is
commenting on interval complement
why
isn't don't we have a function interval
complement he's saying is it because of
the open closed interval issue i think
it is i think we we do not live very
happily with open and closed sets
because we're representing i mean well i
don't know whether we
how do we represent that in an interval
when what is the interval how do we
represent open versus closed
we don't
so this is our intervals is not set
theory they're just primarily made for
um
as a you know the original interval
thing was added as a means of providing
interval arithmetic
so you do functions and you want an
outer approximation to where that
function value is going to be
and so it's always outward rounding so
they're always close they're never open
ever
so we don't but for from a set theory
point of view it makes perfect sense to
want to have open and closed
um but that's not what our intervals are
unfortunately well i think that i mean i
think we have to this is something that
comes up regularly and i think let's put
that on an agenda for probably lcc to
talk about
we've had various designs for this with
various open closed wrappers and things
like this right one can imagine yeah i
think the harder is going to be to
actually implement it well i understand
that but yeah and simple cases are not
so hard but but okay so is somebody
taking notes here can you deal with this
please
to get that i got it okay all right um
now okay by the way in your
documentation here for goodness sake
call it you know x and dx or something
here rather than c and r
okay
okay
um
let's see all right
sandra is commenting do we have to worry
about the possibility of doing circular
ones in the future i think we don't
because roger is telling me that the
theory is far from existing for that
say that again say it again well i mean
the question is whether we need to burn
a box
a box concept
into this interval like centered box
interval i don't think we do
i think centered interval will be used
mostly hold on
i'm missing something what do you mean
sando on our live stream is commenting
do we want to burn into the name of the
thing that we are creating today
something that represents the fact that
it is a coordinate axis box
in case in the future we actually have a
truly circular interval
right and i'm saying no
we should do this partly because the
number one use of this interval will not
be in the complex plane it will be
purely you know on the real line
oh
right
yeah
yeah i think it's
yes
i
i think that if one wants that in the
future like a disc looking thing
then one could name it such that it's
not
yeah i agree i'm not worried about that
okay
so here
i see so so in the case of equal unless
yeah right for intervals equal may just
not resolve in certain cases correct yes
um
what is full specification at the
interval don't we have a different name
for that kind of thing
where are you reading russian there
that's not what we usually call it we
usually call it properties or something
well actually we don't call it
properties we call it
what do we call it usually i mean we
this one is actually would be better if
adam is here so this is a little bit
you know look at here it uses binary
uh
it's a complicated thing okay then we
got to talk about it another time okay
let's put it on the agenda for a
different time
all right
[Music]
so before so this is this is not our
work this is um
frederick johansson um
[Music]
uh did a
swedish guy did a phd risk then this is
sort of has been his hobby project and
part of its phd project and all of that
there's probably 10 years of work
before that we had
we only support interval arithmetic for
elementary functions
um and this is so does this allow us to
then do uh sort of validated route
finding and things for these functions
and so on and we are we actually don't
we shipped it already
yeah you know that's you know when we we
talked about in twelve battle route yes
yeah exactly and we're using it we were
actually using it 10 years ago but not
this library you know different kind of
we use the interval there stuff
but now we've extended it to also
vectors right so so my question is this
i mean in
[Music]
given that
intervalization so to speak
i mean you know what you're effectively
saying is
there are certain proofs we can now do
about functions
right my question is
given that we are moving towards i mean
and this is related to another meeting
that
your
this this meeting that's being tagged as
multi-computation but it's really about
well it's a whole collection of things
but but one of the things is the
representation of proofs so my question
is
in the central arithmetic world
is there some way that we can imagine a
a
proof presentation
about functions
presented using intervals somehow
in other words if you say
gamma of arc cosh of three
is greater than seven
and we come out with true for example
what is the unrolling of that statement
is there a proof
i mean it's not clear we care but but is
there some is that something obvious
where where you know given
that the thing
you know could one imagine tracing the
intervals that are constructed to
determine that
yeah one can
is it interesting
yes this is i mean this is this is in a
way this allows one to shortcut lots of
proofs basically
i understand that i understand that i
mean that's the same thing we've been
doing for years with algebraic numbers
and so on
right but my question is
given that
axiomatically you can say
we have you know assume it's
axiomatically correct that we know what
the correct interval arithmetic is for a
particular function can we at least
given some particular sort of claim
you know i'm just trying to understand
how you would break that down
um
i mean you understand what i'm saying
yeah yeah but but but sort of what you
have is that given an interval n
you get the guaranteed interval
out so if you can say that something is
less than or not i mean
you know when we can decide things are
less than other is when the intervals
don't overlap
right
for instance let's say that you want to
say stand i understand look i okay
forget about this this um i i think it's
an interesting project and i would like
to add it to my
um if somebody can remind me of this
i'll add it to my summer school project
list thing of looking at proofs based on
intervals
and is that something somebody can
remind me about or should i just do it
myself right now
i'll make a note as well thank you which
means you have to send it back to me
right
otherwise it doesn't work
okay
okay
sandra is commenting
about this issue
hmm that's interesting isn't it
explain well this phenomenon here
how come we resolve men but we don't
resolve less time
[Music]
um i think jose needs to be here
okay so let's move that to the lcc
meeting please
is scotty you the one who's dealing with
this wait a minute they do overlap
yes they overlap
so it's not completely obvious i mean
maybe there's a reason that min
no but see min returns an interval
okay min returns an interval it doesn't
give a
you know it doesn't give a
so you're saying if i have two kind of
gaussian blobs
and these are the two gaussian blobs
that it's it's always okay
with the kind of arithmetic that we do
for a round to say that one of the
gaussian blobs is the result of the men
is that correct
i don't think that's what it does i mean
i actually in this
uh yeah i still want jose to take a look
at this to explain more in more detail
because
what it does is an approximation
around is all about approximations so
it's trying to
to not compute the correct decision no i
but it does a sort of a serious
approximation of these well right it's
it's a particular calculus of error
propagation right and that means it's
it's an approximation it commits some
mistakes a sort of some approximation
but one i don't know in this particular
case because min is not super
differentiable
indeed okay lcc meeting please for that
okay next
okay i'm
i'd love to see these i'm sure i'll see
them as i visit various functions i have
to say i've been pretty happy recently
when i go to random function pages
that i actually find useful things there
good yeah it's a big project intended to
mirror basically a function handbook but
give you the tools
of how to fish rather than give you fish
so to speak right
okay
all right let's go to algebra for a
second here um
oh see so
sander is commenting that the symbolic
version of a round
gives some insight about what's going on
oh my gosh
oh that is complicated that is
complicated
well that's a jose thing
i bet he got it right
um i'm pretty sure too but but but it
doesn't mean i could ex
you know immediately i can't do that
with almost any function without
thinking
right
i have to say that that conditional
expression with the true thing i've
never liked very much
that's a piecewise that's a piecewise
okay i meant
yeah i wish there's a better way to
typeset that
i wonder if we should just suppress the
true in the type setting
what do you think
i wish there was a smaller not so long
true like t
well we just make it smaller i mean we
could literally just make it smaller or
just set it as
like that why not yeah that would look
better it would actually
i mean that's that's within our rights
so to speak to do that
let's do it
okay mike make a note whoever makes
notes
and that's for adam i'm sorry that's for
itae
okay
noting take a screen cap of that
um
[Music]
okay let's move on algebra
[Music]
um
almost all those special functions are
my personal friends but riemann xy is
not one i know but i remember when we
introduced it
right
[Music]
um
okay adject
how'd you get this one of those
elementary linear algebra operations
that we should have had 30 years ago yes
i actually don't know what it is
it's basically the inverse but
multiplied by the determinant
a joint classical joint what is it
all right seems uncontroversial yeah
[Music]
why doesn't it have a c also to a joint
does it do we have a function of joint
no we don't
why don't we
i mean i think that a joint name has
gone out of fashion that's the
impression i get from looking lineage
books but maybe i'm wrong what is it
what is it turned into education you get
transpose
a conjugate transpose yeah so the thing
is that adjoint means two different
things yeah i get it i get it right so
that's bad but so wait a minute
conjugate transpose we have and why
doesn't adject refer to conjugate
transpose on the page
uh we could do that yes i made a note
um
okay core potent no potent decomposition
okay these two
they're both sort of related to each
other very closely they are
um they're not as elementary but they're
now making it sort of the most
you know more comprehensive
linear algebra textbooks and there's a
lot of them and so this one
is a type of generalized inverse justice
the more penrose inverse is the type of
generalized inverse
the more penrose
inverse refers to least squares problems
this one refers to invariant subspaces
so when you solve eigen problems
basically
so to understand i mean we call the
other one pseudo-inverse right yes
so this is the the the dress in inverse
is another type of pseudo inverse
generalized inverse
okay
and does these have do they have any
other names that by which they are
commonly known or is this is this pretty
much it this is the only one for russian
inverse yeah and this is inversely
typically mean the more penrose serial
inverse i mean yeah this is the most
common one yeah this is kind of this is
getting more interaction because markov
chain another application will improve
on these nodes stephen i'm not happy
with the notes here right but so what's
the markov chain application
i said
what
yeah uh i haven't looked in that but i
think if your finite markov chain i
think these browser inverses can
identify the nil potent part of the
they break it up so that's the thing so
i mean roughly in a markov chain you
know there's the chain reaction of it it
grows exponentially and there are
certain subspaces in which the markov
chain will will grow only polynomially
yeah yes i mean that's yeah i mean the
neal potent part is the one that goes to
zero if you multiply if you do
sufficient steps it's zero
it zeros it out
that's what neil potent means by the way
slate on our live stream is commenting
that that little true could also be
slightly grayed down and i agree with
that
yeah um
i think so
those are all good comments actually i
think that little tweak would actually
help right so should just do it okay
anyway cornell pertinent decomposition
so why is it in what sense is it
decomposition is it like our other
matrix decompositions where it's given
multiple different things yeah so look
at there what it
scroll up just a tad
to the top the last row there
see you get a core part and a neopotent
part in the diagonal the neopotent part
is the one
that's basically the zero eigen values i
get it and the core are the non-zero
eigenvalues oh yeah i understand it's
just essentially zero yeah right
yeah
okay
update to matrix form
i mean these are lovely i'm sure there
were a lot of work to implement i
shouldn't don't minimize them i just
think from a design point of view
there's not so much to talk about yeah
this is still working on this he'll
bring it up for lcc it's kind of common
to lcc and us so he said he'll tackle it
in lcc i'm sorry but
what's the idea here the idea is to to
display
matrices as matrices not as nested lists
in matrix form i'm well aware of that
idea but what's the specific new idea
here right
you want to be able to put matrix form
into let's say inverse and it should
work oh okay okay that's what he
requested last time so it's done
basically but it i was not happy with
what he had he requested more time and i
said that's fine fine okay i get it
that makes sense
polynomial sum of squares representation
so this is a guy you know so
this is a david hilbert problem
yes um but the sum of squares
representation for integers
is i mean that that's that's whatever it
is the the um oh gosh what is that guy's
name
that i mean that we have functions for
for this for integers right right
what are they
it's power it's power representation
even i think
um we have we generalized to some the
square to powers representation so what
do we call it integer power what do we
call it i think it's called powers
r or something like that
how is powers powers representation
but there's a related function squares
are yeah this is the yeah squares r is a
counting thing right right
okay so this we should have better notes
here this is gosh what is that guy's
name there's a number theorist before
the modern era
who um wearing's problem that's right
wearing
right that should be a key word for this
right
if i'm not mistaken
yes could somebody make a note please
yes
okay
hello
yes i made a note
this isn't much related to the to the
integer problem okay so let me
understand this one here
this is for multivariate polynomials
okay
and so what is it
so the question is let's say that a
multivariate polynomial is non-negative
does there exist a sum of squares
representation
because if they're if you have a sum of
squares representation clearly it's
non-negative sure
right
but the question is yeah this is the
opposite is it the case if it's not
negative that there is a sum of squares
representation that was the hilbert
problem and the answer is no
most of the time it is generically there
is but there are exceptions and in
general you actually need a sum of
squares or rational functions
which was proved in the 1920s somewhere
but the first counter example
to this you know that that you know that
there are non-negative multivariate
polynomials that doesn't have a sum of
squares representation came in the 1960s
okay how complicated is it it's not very
complicated it should be under um
possible issues or
um it's surprisingly simple actually
forget
it's it's in the previous section the
mod skin polynomial yeah
which one
i think earlier
yeah there we go this one
looks like that polynomial
i don't understand no next one next next
one
for god's sake give a message in this
case come
uh the on so so see that we cannot prove
that there isn't
uh
okay
it has been it hasn't been proven that
there isn't we
during the computation we we just didn't
find a representation we may or may not
i think probably given that it is such a
rare case i think you should generate a
message
just saying no representation found
what i'm saying
so i agree
well i hate these unevaluated things
just hate those so
no reason so the issue here is so there
are three cases in which in which we can
we fail
so there is a very common case we fail
to find the representation because the
polynomial is not non-negative and we
can prove that
well but we don't try because it's much
more expensive than this thing
well so you can always say you can
always get away with just saying no
representation found oh so just just in
any case we don't find we say no
representation foundation i would do
without even
have a proof necessarily okay
what this uses under the hood is um
convex optimization
right let's use the semi-definite uh
programming
i'm not surprised what i would have
guessed here it's a cool thing okay so
then
question
why
this really
these are the the summons the square and
so to speak if i say if i see
representation i would expect it to
actually write it
you know to evaluate to turn the
polynomial into a sum of squares which
presumably you don't want to do for some
reason you would prefer to give
the this this you know the whatever they
call them the square hands or whatever
the things that will be squared so you
can use them so you can use temperatures
what would be the typical consumption of
these things
where would you consume them
you understand my question
yes yes
uh
well look under applications
well i would hope that the experts are
here
yeah we really we
so so the most common use is is to prove
non-negativity so in this case we don't
really care with whether
whether we get the actual
things or what format we get the meaning
we it's just why don't you have a
function called non-negative polynomial
q
uh then we would have to
go to harder methods if we if this one
doesn't work
sure
yes but if the question is is the
polynomial non-negative that seems like
a question you might want to answer
and maybe we can only do it to some
extent today but in the future we might
be able to do more of it i mean is it in
fact decidable it must be decidable yes
it is it is disabled and we can decide
it we can you know it's just doubly
exponential in the number of variables
okay well fine but that seems like a
highly useful function to have
polynomial non-negative q
right but it should be in addition to
this one right yes yes yes yes i'm not
suggesting it isn't but i'm just saying
that seems the packaging if you say the
main application is testing
non-negativity then let's give people
that application
so rather than having them mm-hmm
polynomial non-negative q
i think so
okay yeah
i guess it might be useful for linear
algebra for quadratic forms and that
kind of stuff in a way you want to
i would think so yes and i mean
certainly that's what how i've tried to
use in the past so i can i can
absolutely imagine that i generate a
bunch of potential uh quadratic forms
and i say select polynomial non-negative
q yes and that would be i mean it would
be much quicker than doing geometrically
or some other method like eigenvalues or
whatever
right okay so let's look at this
function now i mean that function can
use a variety of methods this exactly i
mean if it's actually quadratic there's
super cheap methods you wouldn't even
use this stuff
right
okay
so now let's understand this one and let
me understand this polynomial systems in
feasibility certificate which sounds
very bureaucratic it is
very bureaucratic
it's the long current longest name
oh is that right well done
yeah we just cheered last
week and realized that
oh my gosh
okay
so it's for proof nerds okay i
understand that but let me make comments
about proof stuff okay we have got
multiple kinds of proofs now and we need
a standard for how we present these
proofs and we need a standard for the
kinds of things you can do with these
proofs like for example for find
equation or proof
okay one of the things we can do is
package it up into a function
where you run the function and it
verifies the proof basically right where
this function has the property that you
know if you evaluate it it will give
true if the proof is correct and the
evaluator is correct
so i like that
right but so i mean but find equation of
proof that's a proof verifier as a sort
of proof checker yeah right but the
point is that find equation of proof
has you know if you look at a proof
object which it's generating and maybe
we should have other things generate
proof objects as well i mean we did have
that in mind when we invented proof
object to find equation of proof okay
and so um
the uh
you know do we have a what what do we
have something called a proof checker
no we it is a property of a proof object
okay so what we have here is the proof
function
okay
we have proof notebook which gives us a
nicely formatted notebook we have you
know all these kinds of things um
the
uh
it's um
um
actually i s steve
makes an interesting point in the in the
livestream chat about the fact that i
keep on you know increasing the the size
of these win windows and yes when i save
a notebook with a certain magnification
that magnification will remember but it
occurs to me and we should bring this up
in the user assistance meeting scott
there's another note for you
some kind of setting that you can give
that says never open a notebook in less
than this magnification and that would
be very useful for lots of presentation
purposes also if you used windows well
done microsoft
um
okay but scott can you make that note
please
yep i got it
okay so in any case the the
um
so you know these are various kinds of
ways to to look at a proof
okay and there's sort of a standardized
concept of what a proof looks like so
for this case go ahead so
the proof verification is is the thing
if you look at the first example
the the
you know
see that
we evaluate the the certificate and then
the the next two
evaluations are are the verification so
this is the independent verification of
the second okay adam
let's be real okay if you want somebody
to verify this right telling them you
have to type all this junk to do it it's
horrifying right if all they want to do
is press the easy button and say now let
me verify this you don't want to have to
say type times at part blah blah blah
blah right do you think i actually
actually have a function
for myself the internal context that
does this so yes well i thought you
would right so so the point is if what
this generated was a proof object
and we standardized on what how a proof
object can generate its proof function
and things like this the proof function
of this proof object would be your
internal function thing and it would
generate a thing which is just a big you
know function function that when you
feed it whatever you feed it will give
true
am i making sense i mean i don't even
understand what is this thing you know
if i if i look at a polynomial's
certificate what do i see there what is
it
i mean you're not even showing me any of
them right uh no it's it's documented
at the top and and it's complicated so
so i don't want to show it because it's
right
that's the same story as a proof object
from find equation on proof is a very
complicated object
you see what i'm saying
so what we're doing here and this
multi-computation thing that we're going
to start talking about soon is a much
more general take on what happens with
this but what we're doing here is we've
got this graph that represents this
essentially multi-way computation and
we've got a piece of it that is our
proof and we are now extracting certain
properties of it
am i making sense
and so what i'm saying is i think we
should generalize that you know we've
got multiple cases which are showing me
a new one here where i mean i don't
think the details of what the
certificate produce
you're not telling me that those are
incredibly valuable things where you're
going to run around and say this is my
private key i'm thrilled about it type
thing right even even in that case if
you look at what we've done with encrypt
and so on which is very nice in my
opinion we have packaging of the private
keys and so on we don't just give you
blump here's this 128-bit thing
you see what i'm saying
right so i mean again in that case it's
like a proof type thing
where we have you know where we've got
the wrapper
make sense like that
yeah okay so
i mean i think that's what we should be
and i think you know we need some kind
of protocol we need a framework and a
protocol
for how to extend proof you know new
proof types exactly well and we have
who's the developer for that who's this
you know this is a jonathan production
proof object but it's had other people
work on it as well okay mano worked on
it it's some but this is about to get
dramatically generalized with this
multi-computation thing and i think
that's the place to look at because
what's going to happen the whole point
about multi-computation and multi-way
graphs and things like this is
right now when we do evaluation the only
thing we care about is the answer
right we don't care about the path
we just say the answer is this
okay in multi-computation you cannot get
away with doing that and for example in
logic programming you would be doing you
know you'd be saying can i find a path
to the goal show me the path
right the path matters right the path is
the proof
and that's and so you know we we start
having to have a bunch of new functions
that deal with paths and for example
incomplete graphs where we have you know
like for this fine equation of proof we
do not have the complete multi-way graph
we only have one proof path but it has
various little tentacles that stick out
that are you know using lemmas from
elsewhere and things like this
so i mean yes we should okay there's one
piece of this which is the
multi-computation piece the other piece
is the general framework for proof
objects and we should separately meet
about that okay but the first thing will
be super useful is to get an inventory
from you guys particularly and i think
from other groups as well
of what things could you imagine
you know feeding into the proof world
that making sense i mean there's also
stuff coming from the compiler where
there are tight proofs
well okay i mean but
okay that needs to be sort of a separate
set of meetings because there's
a lot there's a lot of things i know but
first step to that towards that is let's
just get the list of the 10 functions
you have right now we have right now
that
that deserve proofs i mean we used to
have from long ago we had certificates
of primality we had all kinds of things
like this we've we've had them over the
years we've had little bits
of proof-like constructs
it's now time to bring those all
together and this multi-computation
thing will provide a general framework
for you the algebra is shock full of it
you know row reduce is a proof
okay fair enough you know so
you know as well as all the the other
polynomial stuff so we're fine but let's
just make a list of what things we think
of as being proofs and then what is row
reducer proof of zero determinant or
something
yeah among other things
there's a there's a large set of things
that that you proved from a row reduce
okay
simplification can be thought as proof
of two things being equal yes indeed
right right indeed and it has a path
right which we do not expose right now
simplification will always have steps
but we're never exposing them
yeah well good point i mean expand any
of the any of the algebraic
transformation things is a answer only
type story
right so it's regular from alpha rather
than wolfram alpha pro
doesn't give you the steps
that was supposed to be a joke
yeah
nobody found it at all
um okay so we we will we'll pull we'll
pull and we'll hold back polynomial
system
usability certificate for 13 though fine
i mean you could put it in as a function
repository item if you need it for
something
i mean pull it you know calling into
some internal code the polynomial sum of
squares representation
um
let me just i just we're gonna run out
of time here i have a meeting i have to
go to um
the uh
um
okay well clearly this is just the first
in the series here because we've got
other things to talk about
um
uh
i just want to let's see if we can
quickly close off the polynomial sum of
squares representation
okay i'm concerned about
i'm concerned about that name i don't
think it's a representation i think it's
a decomposition
at best
the problem with decompositions is that
you think that it has to do with
composition
and that's true for all the linear stuff
because composition and multiplication
i'm actually going to argue against
myself here because this is more like a
digit expansion of some kind
what kind of words do we use i mean in
other words when you say integer digits
of something you are getting a thing
from you're getting a bunch of random
digits
from which the number can be constructed
by some more elaborate function
right
so my question is
what is what are the words that we use
around the digits world
for those kinds of decompositions i
think we have digits
we actually have powers representations
which which which is exactly the same
but foreign that's exactly the thing i
brought up first which when you didn't
we weren't here
that's um uh right i mean power's
representations
is
but is this unique the polynomial sum of
squares representation
if it exists is it unique no no
okay
is powers representations for integers
is that all of them or is that also not
unique
it's not
it's not unique but we can give all of
them and in this case
all of them is infinite number
in which case uh in case of polynomials
you can you can have infinitely many
representation in case of integers you
you have finite number and we can give
all of them okay
okay not deficiently but yeah yeah i i
understand
the okay so
okay
i don't know why these aren't p
sub whatever but whatever i don't know
anyway okay what are we going to call
this
i mean i think you could at least take
out the word sum of you could say
polynomial squares representation is
that right is that confusing
what is that representation called i
mean it's usually called sum of squares
it's a quadratic form is it called a
quadratic form or is it not called the
quadratic form it's usually not called
quadratic form because quadratic form
relates to quadratic polynomials only
this is decisions to any degree
it's usually called sum of squares and
people say sos rather than someone's
facebook exactly yeah
polynomial sos a polynomial that sounds
good if that's okay it's kind of a joke
i think it's silly i mean if you see a
piece of code you know this is not
exactly a function which is going to be
shown up
showing up every day and if you see it
it's better that you know what it is
all right
why do we need the word polynomial
though
sum of squares also refers to
integers
and we or or any other functions which
which we cannot compute the
representation
right
okay
do we want to say list instead of
representation would that be a better
polynomial some squares list like a
factor list
what's that like a factor list kind of
thing
yes but i mean polynomial sum of squares
list
suggests you're going to get a list of
things out right that's okay to me yeah
that's good i think
okay
um all right
i think we have to wrap for now um
where do you think we are stephen
we hit it one more time i think we're
about halfway good i think so whoever
is someone listening that does deals
with scheduling here
scott hopefully can take that
information yeah i can pass on to have
another follow-up meeting of about the
same time okay good i think i mean just
looking ahead here
um
i don't know how horrifying so these
don't look like they're going to be that
bad but i don't know i think no they're
not i think that might be well yeah they
will spend a little bit of time at that
the other things there's no
design implications they're more um sort
of
let's hit it for another hour um
sometime soon i look forward to it and
we've got a few things that we we we
snagged on here which we need to talk
about
okay
particularly the function poles
result and that needs adam next time
please
um
okay thanks a lot guys thanks